اهلا بكم الى موجزه لاهم الانباء قال وزير
الداخليه التركي سليمان وصلوا ان قوه
الامن القت القبض على امراه يشتبه بتقيمها
بالعمليه عمليه التفجير التي اودت بحياتي
سته اشخاص يوم امس في شارع الاستقلال
بمدينه اسطنبول التركيه واتهم الوزير وحزب
العمال الكردستاني بالمسؤوليه عن التفجير
اضاف انه تم القاء القبض على نحو 21
مشتبهين فيهم
جانبه قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
انه جهود اسقاط الدوله التركيه من خلال
الارهاب ستفشل اركان الامن التركي قد نشر
صوره لمن قال انها المشتبه في تنفيذها
عمليه التفكير في شارع الاستقلال باسطنبول
كما حصلت الجزيره على صوره لها من زوايا
مختلفه اثناء وجودها في ساحه تقسيم
المؤديه الى شارع الاستقلال
عقد رئيس الامريكي والرئيس الكوريه
الجنوبي والرئيس الوزراء الياباني قمه
ثلاثيه على هامش اعمال لقمه رابطه الاسيان
وقال مستشار الامير القومي
على اي اختبار النووي المحتملين لكوريا
لكنها لا تسعى الى النزاع معها
حطها مع وزير الخارجيه
وحلفائها بتقويض مصالحين في المحيط الهادي
على ضروره ان لا تصبح منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا
مسرح لزراعه دوليه بالوكاله
قالت قياده اركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
صدت محاولاتنا روسيه للتقدم في مقاطعه
دونيت
ان القوه الروسيه كما كانت من احراز تقدم
طفيف على
محورتها بالعنيفه تدور على محور قتال
مدينه
ان المستشاره الامن القومي
خلال لقائه في قياده بضروره الانفتاح على
المفاوضات ونقلته
وفريقه بالبدا في التفكير في مطالب واقعيه
بما في ذلك اعاده النظر في هدفه المعلن
المتمثل بالسعاده اوكرانيا شبه جزيره
العرب
لن تجلس الى طويله المفاوضات مع موسكو قبل
تحقيق شروطها وهي استعاده جميع الاراضي
والمحاسبته مجرميه الحرب
باحتفال الديمقراطيين بالاغلبيه البسيطه
في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي وذلك بعد فوزه
مرشحه الحزب كاسر بمقعد المجلس عن ولايه
نيفادا في انتخابات التجديد النصفي وقال
الرئيس
الامريكيين بسبب السياسه الاجتماعيه
للديمقراطيين في دوله قالت رئيسه مجلس
النواب الامريكي انها نتائج الجمهوريين في
الانتخابات اقل من المتوقع
شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء